well the number 666 is pretty famous or
I suppose you could say infamous 666 is
called the number of the beast and the
reason that the number 666 has become
infamous it's not just because it's some
kind of nice number it has got a lot of
interesting mathematical properties
perhaps disappointingly mathematically
666 not as special but it's famous
because of its use in the Bible where it
is the number of the beast let me read
the relevant passage the one thing that
I do know where it turns up is in the
game of roulette
so roulette here's a roulette table this
is the Monte Carlo roulette table let
him who has understanding reckon the
number of the beast for it is a human
number it's number is 666 there's an
American roulette table as well which is
slightly different the American table
has a zero and a double zero whereas the
Monte Carlo roulette table does hostel
one zero the New Testament the Bible
wasn't written in English this is just a
translation so in the original Greek
manuscripts the number is actually
written as three letters the Greeks
didn't have symbols for writing numbers
they use letters instead it's the same
as if in English we had to use the
letter A for one the letter B for two
and so on
Greek is like this it uses letters to
represent numbers Hebrew is like this
letters are used to represent numbers
and those are the two main languages of
the Bible so all roulette tables though
use the numbers 1 to 36 so so here the
Monte Carlo roulette table has 37 slots
0 1 2 3 up to 36 so alpha the first
letter of the Greek alphabet represents
the number one beater the second letter
represents number two gamma the third
letter represents number three now if we
carried on like this we wouldn't be able
to form big numbers very easily so then
as we go on the letter iota comes to
represent 10 Kappa is 20 and
then we've got a now go to our hundreds
so row which is the equivalent of our
letter R represents one hundred Sigma
the next letter just like we go R s Rho
Sigma in Greek two hundred now what this
means that every word also has a
numerical value the Monte Carlo table
was invented by a man called Francois
Blanc in fact the first version of
roulette was invented by a mathematician
called Blaise Pascal really early
version of the idea of he's ahe's a
brilliant French mathematician really
interesting life but the version I want
to talk about is the Monte Carlo
roulette table so Francois Blanc
invented this and they say that he made
a deal with the devil for the secrets of
roulette because the numbers of a
roulette table add up to six six six so
for example my name is Pete pie famous
mathematical symbol which is the first
letter of my name which would be 80 so
pi p four-peat 80 epsilon and e that
would be 5 tau a T that would be 300 and
finally another e 5 so the number of my
name is 390 is just a coincidence it's a
nice little funny story told by gamblers
who perhaps suffered at the hands of the
roulette table 666 then if it is the sum
of consecutive numbers 1 to 36 that
means it's also known as a triangle
number that's what a triangle number is
let's have a look at those okay so in
the Bible the famous number 666 comes in
Revelation chapter 13 this calls for
wisdom let him who has understanding
reckon the number of the beast for it is
a human number it's number is 666 now in
English this word reckon actually comes
from a Greek word which means calculate
so it's almost like the text is saying
I'm gonna give you a riddle
you need to calculate the number
the beast okay this number 666 actually
relates to a name now in Greek this is
called ISO Sophie the idea that a name
can be your number as well or a number
can be a name and in Hebrew thoughts the
same idea is called gamar tria which
actually relates to our english word
geometry it has the same Greek origin
many people have seen the book of
Revelation as directed against the Roman
Empire so when it comes to calculating
the number of the beast this evil figure
within the book many have them presumed
that this figure must be something to do
with the Empire in particular it's
particularly evil leader Nero so the way
that they this is calculated from the
number 666 is to take the letters of
Nero Caesar but a slight complication is
that the letters are actually written in
Hebrew and not Greek the reason for that
is it's often in Jewish thought in
Hebrew thought that the idea of making
letters and numbers or making names from
numbers have some significance
one way to writes Nero Caesar in Hebrew
is like this now just like in Greek each
letter corresponding to a number the
same is true in Hebrew so the first
letter of the Hebrew alphabet is arlov
so this corresponds to number one bates
corresponds to number two and then we
move into our tens as well so Yad
corresponds to number ten Rach
corresponds to 200 so we have a very
similar system both the Greeks and
Hebrew language use letters to represent
numbers so this says Nero Caesar in
Hebrew the new the end is number 50 the
are the race is 200 okay valve is six
new is 50 cove is 100 some ik is 60 and
then rach is 200 now if you add up all
of these we come to 6
six-six so Nero Caesar the name Nero
Caesar has a numerical value of 666 why
is it spelled slightly funnily we've got
here n are the equivalent of Oh n so
we've got near own Caesar the reason for
that is that the the Greek way of
writing Nero Caesar was near own Caesar
I think this is is the most obvious
explanation partly because there are
other examples at the time in other
Hebrew and Greek texts of this kind of
riddle the idea of a number representing
a name it's convincing because this
neurone Caesar this particular spelling
is in common use and also John as an
author uses very Hebraic contract
concepts he draws on a lot of Hebrew
ideas some people argue that he Greek is
his second language he thinks in Hebrew
but he writes in Greek so he's imbued
with Hebrew ideas but also adds to the
kind of the complexity of it in terms of
it being a riddle a secret so no one
wants to write a book under imperial
persecution saying the root of all evil
is nero caesar you're not gonna spell
that out so this is kind of a way that
the the number system of the time can be
use as a code to kind of protect the
author protecting recipients from an
out-and-out criticism a triangle number
then can be written like a triangle here
I'm going to write out I'm going to take
some dots and write them it squeak in a
triangle and you see each row is a
different number so I've got 1 2 3 4
so the first triangle number is just 1
on its own the second triangle number is
the first 2 rows there so 1 plus 2 which
is 3 the third triangle number is this
triangle 1 2 3 which is 6
the fourth triangle number is that and
so on and so on and the 36th triangle
number so the very last row would have
36 dots on it would be 36 triangle
number that is 6 6 6 6 6 sixes has been
used to indicate virtually anything but
anyone who's been
evil and evil ruler ozone has been found
to add up somehow to the number of 666
using all sorts of bizarre counting
systems what generally happens is that
people take the English alphabet A to Z
and use the numbers 1 to 26 to try and
come up with some code but you can see
that that's actually nothing like the
genuine way that Hebrew and Greek use
their numbers because they're in Hebrew
and Greek we get units tens and hundreds
whereas these codes that tend to be made
up these days use just a number 1 to 26
a to Z and then they involve all sorts
of bizarre things like adding people's
middle names and so on to come up with
present-day figures of course we know
about the association's who are with 666
but mathematically speaking it's not a
particularly interesting exciting number
it for its own sake it's a more of a
cultural important number what's very
interesting about this 666 is that some
manuscripts some other early manuscripts
from the 3rd century and so on actually
have the number 6 1 6 so the number of
the beast in these texts is 6 1 6 now
what's interesting is that if you take
off this final n in Hebrew and have just
Nero Caesar that equals 6 1 6 so in
other words people are saying I already
know that the answer is Nero Caesar but
I'm not sure about how you worked it out
I'm gonna correct it if you like I think
the number ought to be 6 more 6 so in a
way that confirms that they were
thinking of Caesar Nero Caesar even from
the 2nd 3rd century and so on really
early on so that's a nice bit of
evidence that confirms that certainly
among the early Christians the answer to
this riddle was Nero Caesar in this coil
and
here we go I'm gonna add one 255 so it
carries yeah